entire communities underwater this is
what remains of one home in the northern
state of Uttar Pradesh torrential rain
proving too much for some buildings now
destroyed some see what is some of the
biggest problem here is that day by day
the water level is rising the water has
entered houses as you can see the
powerful weather system drenched the
state for more than 24 hours
affecting close to 600,000 people
schools were closed down and thousands
of displaced families have been moved to
relief camps it's not known how long
they'll be allowed to stay and as the
rain came down the death toll went up
dozens have drowned while others were
killed as buildings collapsed relief
efforts are under way with authorities
trying to drain floodwaters we've seized
up temporary and permanent pumps there's
a problem with water logging at three or
four locations the water's being removed
by cutting the road and creating
channels flooding isn't uncommon in
these areas but the timing is India's
monsoon season normally retreats at the
start of September intense rainfall in
many parts of the country has triggered
floods that have swamped huge areas
eleven people were killed when flash
floods hit western India on Thursday the
heavy rain can be said to be
unprecedented because of this a large
amount of water entered low-lying areas
and caused a lot of damage there is the
possibility that some people were swept
away as the cleanup continues many are
trying to get on with daily life Nicola
gage
al-jazeera